i i have to ask because you've seen our
drift special
who was the best drifter you and why was
it me thank you thank you
i mean was that really the question you
needed to ask there i wanted to just
make i should have wanted to show you
guys
you might as well just ask the question
alexis can you just give me a hand job
yeah i just want to whip your dick right
out
right now it's ready it's okay i already
got his paypal email so it's
slips in the 20. it looks like no okay
okay i must admit even though we clowned
on you in the episode you clearly were
the best drifter you just [ __ ] up in
the game
from the end i mean that touches
[ __ ] because you
clearly won the election well you were
the most sort of confident with it so
you got a bit too
hectic with it yeah that's why yeah i
would like to argue though that the
starting position was a little
different you know like like you you
were clearly
the most i mean you were the most
excited you were the most experienced
driver
driving out of all of us like i said
before it's
it you all got to like i watched the
video and i thought oh yeah that's about
right like from what i've seen it wasn't
really
different like if you haven't you know
the prerequisite for learning how to
you know maybe learn how to ski the
prerequisite is being able to stand up
like yeah
if you can't stand up then you're not
gonna be able to do it like so if you're
not used to
oh you know drifting uh to driving a
manual car uh for such a long time
also those cars have a clutch which is
kind of
that clutch was weird yeah yeah well
they're designed was it making it like a
rattling sound when you
yeah yeah and also i i feel like a
normal clutch like
if i touch it a slight bit i feel it in
the car yeah this one i had to [ __ ]
slam it down
anything out of it so the i mean the
clutches in those because you know
you're constantly
slipping them so yeah yeah so the the
clutches are made to take a lot of heat
and also makes sense they're kind of
grippy so yeah they're not easy to drive
so they're definitely not easy to drive
yeah the car looks fairly
didn't look too extreme yeah they're
kind of a pain in the ass look even i do
that i
i left my my mark ii at the uh
the tuner shop like last week and he
lent me
like his drift car like one of his
personal drift cars just as the courtesy
car
right right what this he's like yeah i
got too many of them just take that one
i've got too many
too much in the way and i stalled it
twice before leaving the car park and
he's like
he's like alex you suck i'm like yeah
whatever man
because everyone knows like it's always
hard to jump into someone else's car
yeah i'm just like only two damn
i stole like eight times trying to move
forward it was all right
yeah you weren't it would be good it was
it was like you'd be able to drive a
normal manual car because
even for me i like i stored it a lot and
i've like
i i've gotten used to it but like the
biting point is like so small
and it feels like you're gonna break the
car right as well right
and you go like one millimeter above and
it just stalls right like there's no
leeway at all
yeah they're a little bit tricky but
yeah and you all did really good i was
it was an enjoyable video and
uh even i enjoyed watching the whole
thing oh my god yeah that's good
that's a w i i wonder how cause we
obviously didn't get to go on the the
serious track or anything right
how do you transition from just doing
your little [ __ ] donuts to like
actually going on a track like because
there has to be something like how do
you is there like a test
how do you in between that because how
do you learn because it seems like there
wasn't really a way
like it was it's just a slow progression
of um
like there is a little bit of a sort of
a wax on wax off approach to it where
it's like
you do the donuts right then you do
those you did the handbrake turn like
the parking
yeah but then what you do is you do the
handbrake turn
but then you transition to doing a donut
then that's a drift
right you didn't get to that point
that's okay yeah okay normally it takes
people a bit longer if you haven't
done any sort of car stuff before like
like that so it's just a slow
progression like you start off going
slower then you build a bit of speed
then you get a bit too overconfident you
spin out a lot then you start to okay
let's dial it back a bit and it's just
it's just slowly slowly building up
it's kind of like what i've noticed is
so i used to play video games like a
quake
arena and stuff like that boomer stuff
sort of thing back in the day
and you know but then i gave it up for a
long time never played shooters and then
all this whole the whole br thing
started beginning and i thought oh this
is actually cool like a lot of people
you're paying real people whatever
it wasn't like ces i didn't really get
into that and i started
i noticed that like you know watching
people you know pros playing again
is that they just sort of jump in it's
like first game's a dub it's like yeah
yeah
because they've just been doing it for
so long yeah whereas i noticed
like if i get in it's like the first two
or three games it's like yeah my aim's
off i'm terrible
yeah yeah same thing with drifting you
start off it's like
you got to like recalibrate everything
and it
just gets better and better and the
better you get the faster you can
hit corners really well compared to when
you're a beginner like it might take
until the end of the day
you finally get that corner right i
entered at a good speed the car
didn't go too sideways i kept my speed
up yeah and you get that huge rush and
then you
get that again and again and again again
yeah and honestly it
doesn't the rush doesn't get any worse
like it doesn't get any lower
you just you just end up going faster
more angle you know more
more speed power power the orgasm just
gets more intense
you're really selling me on this so like
okay how how long would you would you
say it takes to from like
coming from nothing to going on like one
of the tracks that isn't like the
practice track
i mean you can do it straight away like
they have other tracks which are kind of
smaller
right but i mean i'd say i've been
drifting
uh let's see for like 20 years goddamn
and i'm pretty confident like i could
probably i've never actually driven like
a
top level car before i'm pretty
confident if you give me a few laps i'd
be okay at it like i'm not a top level
driver i've got the
i hold the second highest i've got like
a like a
diamond license sort of right like i'm
like a diamond ranked driver
for a long time but i can confidently
drive pretty much any track that's been
20 years
if you it depends on you but if you
drifted every if you drifted
two or three times a week like say say
you got every suit you went there two or
three times a week
it would maybe take you two weeks or so
to be pretty confident most of the
tracks depending if you crashed or not
right okay yeah like yeah the crash is
definitely yeah
crashes are uh they [ __ ] people's heads
right when they like i seem like they're
mental towards like drifting if they
crash
some people some people i've seen people
quit drifting yeah yeah
yeah it's like they'll like they'll
they'll blow their engine or they'll
crash and they're like i'm done yeah i'm
done
yeah yeah like i've seen one guy
actually sell his car at the track
to some to another guy like a guy who
had a truck there with an empty truck
he's like you want to you want to what
do you want to do with this do you want
me to tow you back to where he's like
man i just want to sell it
so the guy was it was a deal it was a
car deal he's like yeah but he's cash or
buy from me
okay that's about rage quit yeah
so yeah people just give up because like
it's a it's a huge like
once you crash a car then it's it's a
big like decision
yeah yeah it's like it can cost like
several thousand dollars even to get it
back to
and it's it's a crashed car now it's not
perfect anymore yeah
it's not good you might from that crash
you might have all sorts of things
happen
so yeah be really expensive some crashes
you can be lucky it's just a bumper
other ones it's like you bend the whole
frame and
the whole car is a write-off and it's
just parts now jesus yeah